were you going to be a part of the uh
Kanye West interview that didn't happen
yeah
was that that was the Nick Fuentes thing
uh-huh so shout out to my guy guilty so
guilty is a guy behind the scenes I
don't know how he does it but he he
contacts everybody he's put he's put a
lot of this stuff together the first
Nick Fuentes interview he actually uh
got raised that I was gonna say that was
kind of a weird because I didn't know
anything about Nick Fuentes and I've
seen you guys talk about like how like
you know we probably
you know it probably wasn't the most
productive conversation no I didn't know
anything about this dude and I just saw
I think I saw Adam talking about it
somewhere or just like people are gonna
be pissed about this I was like oh let
me see what the who the [ __ ] this guy is
I was like oh this guy's kind of like a
he's kind of like a white nationalists
no but even even that situation that
showed me like
you have to I have to do my due
diligence and before you talk to anybody
to talk to anybody you know like I just
a lot of times I get to just use my
personality and Coast on certain stuff
and I'm not even putting myself in a
situation where I gotta hold it down for
my culture and I have to hold it down
for my people being an African-American
man so if somebody has viewpoints and
they're sitting there saying some stuff
to me and I don't know how to counter
that you know it's kind of like a
letdown for my whole community so that
that first interview showed me where
it's like okay I need to be more
prepared and I just can't not study and
not you know get all the facts before I
jump in the ring with somebody like that
was that a interview that you you got
negative feedback from from like like
just like you said like did people think
you didn't do enough yeah they're like
they're like you should have said this
you should have known this you should
have known that and I agree I'm like
yeah I I I should have did way better
when it came down to that because you
know not knowing the history like that's
not no excuse right I have all these
resources I'm in position people look up
to me and I feel like I got to be a good
representation for them so if somebody's
coming at my people or saying certain
certain things like I got to be able to
count it and do an intelligently so when
the Kanye thing was about to happen oh I
did you were ready I was studying for
like three days didn't nobody know I
didn't tell nobody but I literally was a
deep diving getting all my facts
together because I'm like if anybody say
anything I'm about to I'm about to be
there what ended up happening just they
just didn't pull up I think Kanye just
canceled on everybody yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's crazy that would have been
a legendary it would have been legendary